I'm John McGee I work for a Wolfram
research in the Technical Services Group
work remotely out of Southwest Virginia
my talk is about a package for elliptic
curves
well good morning thanks for showing up
hopefully you'll learn something I know
I did and we're preparing this so
elliptic curve package for Mathematica
it's going to be introduced at a basic
level one of the real themes I think is
having a good algorithm is a lot better
than having a million computers so we'll
see as that goes goes through so a
little background what's an elliptic
curve an elliptic curve over a field is
the zero set of a non singular cubic
polynomial in two variables at least in
the basic sense as the equation or the
form indicates there where the degree is
three it's also an algebraic variety
typically anyway the general form of a
cubic of degree three is shown there but
for an appropriate change of variables
over fields that don't have
characteristic two or three because
essentially you have to divide by two or
three to do the change of variables you
get this simplified called the short vyr
stress or just fire Strauss form and the
condition for not being singular meaning
at least over the reals over r2 means no
kinks and no crossovers right
differentiable everywhere so some
general curves briefly they can have all
kinds of shapes when you use the general
equation all kinds of crazy interesting
shapes and forms what makes them
interesting why are they important well
in my examination of these objects it
turns out they lie at the intersection
of a lot of interesting branches of
mathematics number theory geometry both
in the high school sense and in the real
sense group Theory commutative ring
theory complex variables and beyond so
they they really act as a focal point of
deep study they're used as a tool in
algebraic number theory the congruent
number problem that is
do I have if is the number such that
it's the area a rational number that's
the area of a triangle with rational
sides can be worked with elliptic curves
and famously Pharma's last theorem was
proven Andrew Wiles and Taylor and many
others using elliptic curves they're
used practically in computational number
theory such as the elliptic curve
integer factorization that's found in
the you know the great internet prime
search and also there's an ECM in
Wolfram as part of Wolfram's tools for
factoring large composites and in
cryptography those are a couple of
techniques that are used for employing
elliptic curves for cryptography with
the main advantage that elliptic curves
because the discrete log problem is
harder there than it is in other places
you can use smaller fields and so here's
the idea to start we can create a gr a
geometric arithmetic of points by
defining the sum of points as the
reflection about the axis of symmetry of
the third point of intersection and so
here's a little example and we need the
reflection not just the third point of
intersection of a line between two
points in order to get an identity and
inverses as we'll see but so we can
change these around and then what
happens when the points are the same
well we can use the tangent line and
this gives us a nice arithmetic ability
to add points on the curve
algebraically that has a form where the
slope lambda is either rise over run
simple formula or the implicit
differentiation of the Weierstrass form
will give you that and then you can find
the point the third point of
intersection nicely without heavy
algebra no following way I think this is
live
yeah so if you intersect the line with
the curve you can replace y squared with
the right hand side of the lines term
squared and has been run now it hasn't
gone so
resolution change okay sorry
okay
so laying the computer do the algebra
simply I can find the equation that
matches those two it's a cubic in X and
then equate that to the factored form
where I already know two solutions the
two points I started with so the third
point must be the third factor and then
we can let the algebra system equate the
coefficients of x squared which is known
quantities on the left side lambda
squared and we know two of the three
factors on the other side so we get the
nice expression and then the point lies
on a line so the y coordinate is simple
but an interesting thing about this
algebra is that the resulting
coordinates of the Third Point or the
reflected Third Point our rational
functions of the input coordinates means
integers in rationals out rationals and
rationals out any field element in and I
stay in that same field when I do the
point arithmetic and that's an important
attribute of this arithmetic but we
don't have a group yet and to get the
group we have to go into projective
space we can think of projective space P
2 as the set of all directions or lines
in R 3 that pass through the origin more
technically it's the equivalence class
of all triples where two triples are
equivalent if one is a multiple of the
other and we have a copy of r2 in there
simply considering the points that the
equivalence class was equals one but
there's extra points that aren't in r2
we call those the points of infinity and
they all have Y is equal zero as their
coordinates we can transform our
original Weierstrass elliptic curve into
projective form by multiplying through
by Z cubed as shown there the standard
technique and it gives us a homogeneous
polynomial in the three variables so
each term is of total degree three and
homogeneous polynomials have the
characteristic that if XYZ is a solution
then so is KX
because we get a factor of K cubed in
each of the terms so when Z equals one
we plug the equals one we get the
original curve back but when Z equals
zero we get a new solution and this is
the magic that so when Z is zero the
homogeneous equation reduces to X cubed
equals zero and that gives me a new
triple root that's the point in
projective space since X is forced to 0
but Y is free so any value of y works
and that corresponds to a vertical line
projective space took me a little while
to figure out how to represent this
nicely but there's a picture that I like
the upper plane is that Z equals zero
and every point on that plane
corresponds to one of the points in
projective space the line through the
origin but not including it are the
equivalence classes but as we get
further and further out at Z equals one
those lines become almost parallel to
the plane but they never get there so
the extra points in projective space are
the ones that z equals zero representing
the directions in the base plane so it
turns out with this extra point that
satisfies the homogeneous equation we
get a nice group law P plus Q using the
addition formulas above the algebraic
addition formulas now P Plus that
infinity point gives me P back and I
also get inverses in a similar way it's
commutative because algebraic well
geometrically if I add two points put a
line between two points it doesn't
matter which one I pick first the third
points always the same and if so see
tippity is a little hard to prove it's
murder
algebraically to prove but using a
little bit higher math mathematics it's
not too hard that this is also
associated so you get algebraic group
out of these points and just an
illustration of why the point at
infinity works if I take P and add that
point in infinity what I do is take the
third point of intersection which is
this guy and reflect it back and I
end up where I started at the original P
and inverses worked the same way if I
take P and negative P and add them the
third point of intersection is the point
in infinity and it's its own
additive inverse so we get a nice group
law ok the order of a point basic
algebra a point has finite order n if n
times P which were in an abelian group
so NP we're really working in the Z
module representation that is NP is
really P plus P plus P n times if I get
the identity and then is the smallest
one then that's the order of the point
and we can compute NP efficiently using
the binary expansion of the integer
multiple I expand it in the powers of 2
and then NP is just well the product
through distributing P across that and I
only have to do the addition for the
nonzero binary digits bi and so that
gives me a pretty efficient order log in
additions of the operation
another interesting subset to examine if
I look at points only of order N or
divisors of n they're denoted this way
so that's all points of order dividing
in and a fairly deep theorem says that
that's a isomorphic to two copies of Zn
integers mod n but to find all the
points that is n square to those points
we have to look into the algebraic
closure so not all of them are in the
base field so how do we find the order
of a point well if it's a small curve we
can find the order directly by using
shanks baby-step well we can find it
directly by just computing NP otherwise
shanks baby step giant step is effective
what we do is given a point we compute
another point that's the field power
plus 1 times the point and then look for
a match between two lists a lists of
multiples of P and a lists of Q plus K
times
M V where m is approximately the square
root of the field power and we get a
match between those two lists pretty
quickly because of the birthday paradox
essentially probabilistically although
the algorithm is deterministic in that
it searches far enough to guarantee
finding a solution eventually so if we
find that match that is JP is that we
can collect terms in P and we know that
this resulting number M must be a
divisor of the actual point order it's
an effective algorithm but it's not so
good and that it's not polynomial and it
took me a while to get my head around
this it Q to the 1/4 or P to the 1/4
doesn't sound so bad but imagine it
takes 10 microseconds to add two points
of 10 digits then if you go to 10 to the
hundredth power or 10 to the hundred and
tenth power moulting multiplying by 10
to the 100th then 1/4 like 4th root of
that would be a 25 digit number that
would be the multiple of the time it
takes so microseconds go to seconds with
ten to the sixth go to years with
another 10 to the sixth so you're still
left with a number that's 10 to the 13th
digits are so long x in years of how
long it would take to go to the step so
this is not feasible for large q one of
my adventures I attempted to parallelize
shanks algorithm and it revealed
something interesting about Mathematica
actually it's always bad to paralyze
something where you have to move a lot
of data around between the cores to
build up the Jaypee list essentially
adding the point to itself over and over
again that list usually is about a
million points in it in a real problem
we need to say if we save over only the
x coordinates and make an associate
that map's the x-coordinate to the
actual multiplier then we can do the
other search for the QP q + k NP this
way essentially what it's doing is doing
constant lookups in that Association I
tried to paralyze this but I realized
that dividing that list into four pieces
over four processors makes the list 1/4
of the length which has no effect on the
lookup time because the lookup time and
the Association is almost constant time
almost independent of size so the
overhead of trying to paralyze this
didn't really help much but an
interesting lesson of a third case where
well our associations are so efficient
that making them shorter doesn't help
okay so we're after not only point order
but the size of the group which is
critical for both theoretical studies
and for cryptography it turns out you
can get the right algorithm if you're on
a particular elliptic curve this is a
theorem that Gauss proved and in this
simple case we can compute the order
directly using essentially a formula
that has two cases here's an example of
this for the two cases a curve of order
31 that's 31 is 1 mod p so we get some
extra points on that curve but the nice
thing it's a direct formula for the
number of points without actually doing
extra work it's straightforward in the
more general case it's a lot harder so a
simple approach to group order a couple
of basic theorems of algebra the order
of a point must divide the order of the
group LeGrande a beautiful theorem of
haast bonds what the order of the
elliptic curve group is that is the
points with coordinates in the base
field to within plus or minus 2 square
roots of the field size so if we know
the order of a set of points and the
least common multiple is
that range then we have the group order
a couple of notes though if I find a
single point with an order bigger than
that size and that can only be one
multiple of it within the houses range
so it must be that multiple of it must
be the group order and the interesting
observation that if this field contains
one or more points with order that big
than a randomly chosen point is likely
to have a large order because the size
of this entire collection including the
points in infinity goes as N squared so
I did a little experiment using a
parallel version of group order so
here's a reasonably sized curve 30
digits or something and I chose a
thousand points on the curve and did
their point orders by parallelizing the
algorithm and you can see that there is
a nice quadratic shape to these but
every single one of these points is
large enough to uniquely determine the
group order so if the determination of
group order was efficient this would be
a great solution you pick a point at
random the multiple of its order is
unique in the hospice so you're done but
unfortunately the baby step giant step
algorithm grows too fast so briefly Rene
scoffs brilliant invention was to first
construct a set up well use a set of
polynomials that are 0 precisely on
points of order and or points dividing
and the division polynomials their
degree grows quadratically but we can
keep them simple and reduce by modding
both over the curve that is replacing
all pot even powers of y with an even
power of X and also of course modding by
the the field that we're in these
polynomials can be used to construct a
specific split polynomial rational
function actually formula for a multiple
of a point and B by the way they're
built the Y's will never be there wise
only existing odd powers of these
polynomials but it's not a good way to
compute NP what it's used for is scoffs
algorithm using hostas theorem what
scope does is select a set of small
primes whose product is at least the
total width of the Hussle bounds and
then for each of these Prime's determine
the missing element in the formula for
the group size mod those small Prime's
using polynomial arithmetic where my
prop my multiples of points in the basic
formulas are replaced with the division
polynomial based formula once I know
t-mod all these small Prime's I can get
the actual full tee back using the
Chinese remainder theorem the problem is
the size of these polynomials grows as N
squared and so it dies at around 80 or
90 digit numbers the solution provided
by no Mel Keys and Atkins was to find
special Prime's so that there's divisors
of the division polynomials that grow
linearly with the prime size and this
gives nice performance order log to the
sixth power of n so going back to the
multiplied by a hundred digit number
assuming this is base ten that's a
hundred and you get a hundred to the
sixth which is only twelve million only
what twelve digits multiple so you're
one microsecond becomes a couple of
hours maybe instead of thousands and
thousands of years okay just a quick
example of running scoffs algorithm
here's a
some time passes on a curve we get all
of these modular relationships for the
missing element and we use the Chinese
remainder theorem put them back together
and we get the group size as Q or P plus
1 plus or minus that guy plus in this
case and this ran in five thousand eight
hundred ninety nine seconds of about two
hours okay this is related one of the
reasons you care about group order and
point order is because the discrete log
problem given a point and some month of
unknown multiple of it find the K if the
group order is bad like a prime or a
smooth number which is the product of a
bunch of small prime factors then there
are attacks that make the discrete log
problem used in cryptography to easy to
solve so where are we we have a package
that does basic arithmetic I've spent
some time struggling with moving old
large notebook code into package form
but where I'd like to go with this is
into elliptic curves oversee the way
pairing I've done some work
mathematically but not yet
algorithmically I've been a little busy
with other things so that's where we are
so far the package will be available
interestingly all the work that I've
been trying to do was done by Crandall
and Pomerantz a nice book with
Mathematica code called prime kit which
no longer exists on the internet
anywhere I suspect one of two things
it was really bad Mathematica code and
Stephen had it pulled or it was really
really good Mathematica code in the NSA
owns it thank you
questions I guess no it's pulled from
there too no seriously yeah it looks
like it was very formally scrubbed
there's lots of websites that claim they
have it but there it's not there so
anyway Prime KITT yes yeah yeah oh it's
not even available internally as near as
I can tell so and I'm I just discovered
this on Friday so I'm not sure where it
went but it would have been nice to have
that code okay any other questions right
thank you